in my immediate life a 911 played a big
part for me and it was somewhat of a
wake-up call because I think that people
were they knew about the statistics in
the developing world they knew about the
poor they knew about the oppressed but
for some reason this all now came to the
forefront for people and in there was an
urgency of sorts I also was impacted a
number of years ago actually by one of
my sisters who had a touch with with
death she was diagnosed with ovarian
cancer and what I found was that her
struggle really affected me I found
myself asking if I only had a month to
live do I like Who I am where I am what
I'm doing the legacy that I left behind
and I looking deep within I didn't like
the person that I had created all those
years I had been a lawyer for over a
dozen years I spent most of my time
billing clients and working very hard
and I that was a big change for me and i
ended up i'm at that point taking what
was a two-year sabbatical and i moved to
africa and my life was really never the
same afterwards
you